how do I make my characters more than
just a caricature in early drafts we're
just we're again putting pain to the
canvas and they they'll they'll be
caricatures and they'll they'll be
cliche and I I talk to my students a lot
where they're like oh I'm so worried
this feels cliche or fabricated I'm like
don't worry it is cliche and fabricated
but keep massaging it and even then when
you're when you're working on conflict
um we are fabricating conflict with the
it's we're storytellers so we have have
to take the normal conflict of everyday
life and smash it together to make it
interesting because if we s if I mean if
if let's say I'm a character through my
life and like my like driving on the Los
Angeles freeways it's um that might be a
story a very boring story um but it's uh
but then again maybe there's something
in that where there could be a film from
the point of view of a guy driving Los
Angeles freeways and with that is when
we go to the craft and keep going hey
that's a really dumb idea and feel free
to take that dumb idea but it's it's
something where oh wait okay this
character can do this this character can
can go there it's showing up to the page
every day that's that's the main thing
just show up show up show up what's your
process of incorporating supporting
characters predetermined or added as you
go for me it's added as I go um
I
will I write the especially in first
drafts I'm writing the characters I'm
writing the story about as fast as my
hand can write and then um and then all
of a sudden something will show up and a
character shows up and something
interesting go oh wow that's interesting
and then it's just characters start to
take play start to start to find their
way in and then some characters stay in
and some characters leave so the
character kind of has to prove
themselves and other times characters
may sound the same so you can smash
three characters into one character so
uh I add as I go but they're you know
either or because predetermined is
someone who would work from an outline
and kind of come with the strug they
they can come with the whole family tree
of characters before writing a single
word and so that's where writers uh when
they just kind of understand their
process and understanding their process
is just continuing to show up to the
page every day then going oh wait I I
like the family tree of characters or I
like uh my friends call me a pancer cuz
I I do things by the seat of my pants um
so I just like to I just like to throw
paint and then try to make it pretty
later uh by coming back to it day after
day which may not be the quickest way to
get work done but it's just the way that
I personally do it so you so learning
your process is the way to go and have
you written supporting characters and
then said you know you know what I think
this one has to go oh yeah oh yeah no
there's I kill a lot of Darlings and um
I yeah I I've had to kill a lot of
Darlings over this last year and uh in
that in the novel that I now have
finished but um oh great yeah but the uh
yeah it hurts you're like oh man but
it's you know sometimes they upstage the
the journey or they upstage as a
protagonist and it's all about serving
the story serve serve your protagonist
but by creating that conflict that stays
within the um within the world that
you've created what's the first thing
you would do if you were beginning to
write characters for a series that's a
really good one because a Series has to
carry Seasons so when you're when you're
thinking about characters you're also
thinking about World building a lot more
and and thinking about okay I can write
the pilot and also when I'm pitching I
have to know Season 1 Arc season 2 Arc
season 3 Arc or if you're writing a
sitcom you have to know the world of
where they have the um what do you call
it the enclosed story of each episode
like a procedural too a lot of
procedurals have their enclosed stories
and it's just like and we wrap up oh boy
we got him this time but wait till next
week when we are not sure if we'll get
him
um so yeah it's if you're beginning to
write characters for
series play with play with the beauty of
the form of the series what's what's the
series about the series has to have
Series has to have a tone unto itself
that last for a very long time and then
that at that point you can say a feature
film is almost a short story and a
series is a novel or series of novels
and that's when the world of is um the
world of is important in a film too but
really have fun with the world of where
you're putting them even a even a TV
show like friends or like Seinfeld
you're putting Seinfeld on uh his little
you know in his apartment a lot and
Friends they're all in the cafe uh they
all have their conflicts um and for for
a lot of TV series they are um they are
tied in the sets that are created so I
guess on that note think about keeping
your locations as minimal as possible
how do you keep your locations as
minimal as possible so if you're working
on a film I mean if you're working on a
TV series they can shoot as much as
possible on a Sound Stage before having
to go out and do all the exteriors in
your opinion which character traits make
Colonel Jessup A Few Good Men such a
polarizing and Unforgettable villain I
just I just watched it filmed this last
year and assigned it to my students oh
that great yeah it's um it's
it's his moral code is so stringent and
his status is always high well talk
about status play that court scene is
one of the most beautiful Court scenes
to watch in the very end where I think
it's an 8 minute scene where it's just
like watching status shift from uh
Colonel jessip to the uh Tom Cruz's
character back and forth um that's just
a lot of status shifting but the what
what Colonel Jessup has as a as a trait
that is very positive in humans is he
has insatiable dve Drive insatiable
drive to do everything he can that he
feels is right to protect everybody and
even though it's utterly flawed from his
from our point of view it is not flawed
from his point of view and it's just I
feel like that it's there's just
something about it and and it's just
Jack
Nicholson I think reading Colonel Jessup
on the page and then watching Jack
Nicholson be Colonel Jessup just so gr
here we go Amelia films what makes a
character memorable especially villains
I like that question it sometimes the
villain needs to be more interesting
than the protagonist because the more
the protagonist goes through their
journey and the more interesting the
villain is the more the protagonist has
to go through the obstacles of this
interesting and powerful villain so even
though the the villain is the antagonist
they are the protagonist of their story
so yeah Batman is such Batman's such a
great
um example of that cuz cuz Batman yeah
okay he's kind of interesting but the
villains are always more interesting
than Batman
is as far as the TV series I don't know
what the other stuff is no I'm kidding
um uh but it's but but things like
Batman and Spider-Man they they hold the
center of the story and then those
villains just make those villains pop
give them the weirdest quirks in the
world um give them you don't even need
to write well I feel like you need to
write the backstory of everything and
write just and know your character
inside and out but when you're putting
it to script or you're putting it to a
novel you don't need to have that all in
there you just write them from knowing
what their background is from knowing
why they are so messed up in the head
and have this Twisted angle on life and
it's the villains are beautiful so just
make sure that um and kind of make them
lovable too I mean you I if you're
working on a character for you know say
a couple years you really got to like
you almost have to love your character
even if they're the jerks of the film
you have to understand and have empathy
because in order to order to write and
keep the process going we have to love
our characters if we're not coming to
the mour and writing with love that's
kind of a sad place to be I mean come
come with you know self-destructive hate
and go how am I going to do this this is
never going to work uh but at the same
time when it comes to our characters we
love them because we want to take them
on the most interesting Journey that we
can put them
through right and do you think um we
like uh characters that are more
self-destructive rather th than those
that are destructive toward
others because maybe we can relate or
yeah yeah we can relate and it's yeah I
think you're right the the
self-destructive ones I feel like I mean
I really hope everyone has some self
sabotaging things they do to themselves
because I'm the king of it so I
immediately relate to that whereas uh
people who have out you know I I think
so I think I that's a good that's a good
uh thought because as
viewers that's easier to connect with us
when people are out when outright
pushing out and hurting other people
most of us don't do that and even when
we're at our worst we won't hurt someone
else we or you know I like Allen clothes
and be really upset but sure but it goes
in it doesn't go out uh if it goes out
too much there might be a sociopath type
level thing which is fun to watch so
much fun to watch not fun to
be